I mean best case scenario November MSG
you know me and Patty on that main card
pay you oh um but if he needs if he
needs uh December Vegas you know that
that doesn't sound too bad either
I think would you jump across the Pod
and fight him in his his own backyard
too
a hundred percent man that I would love
to go to London and fight him there I
think that would be so cool going going
like you know uh like enemy territory
you know I got a lot of love in London
as well I bet um but it would be so cool
to go there never been
now London
what is up fam it is Monday Monday happy
Monday how are the kids everybody doing
well how's the dog
how's those cats of yours how's the
lizards fish still popping great grand
wonderful happy Monday everybody I am
fresh off the plane from Denver Colorado
went back to my hometown I was a guest
of one championship at the Broomfield
Event Center
to witness their amazing Amazon Prime
card and uh they broke ground for the
first time ever in the United States
soil and they did not disappoint I've
heard from uh many of people who I trust
and respect like dude you got to go to
one Championship the production you know
just the visuals it's just different and
I'm obviously hardcore UFC so I'm like
okay we'll see how it goes and uh Eddie
Brown was probably the first one tonight
he's like dude I'm telling you you've
never seen anything like it and you know
Eddie did commentate he's I think he's
commented on Pride before so Eddie's
been around that culture and you know he
knows he knows the stuff when it comes
to the fight game so I trust Eddie but
even then I still had my doubts boy they
did not disappoint because Broomfield
Event Center is where I came up as a
young strapping uh
lad in the fight game all my fights
before the UFC except for one was at the
Broomfield Event Center I haven't been
back since so you're talking you know
over 15 years ago when I came up in the
regional circuit out there in Broomfield
Colorado during the ring of fire which I
don't think is around anymore
um but a couple of alumni from Ring of
Fire would be Donald Cerrone
um shankarwin uh Elliott Marshall
um and Leonard Garcia fought in the uh
Ring of Fire the who's who that came out
of Denver Cody Donovan Christian Allen
um the who's who's fought in in the ring
of fireman so it was a big deal back in
the day now I think it's gone which is
makes me sad either way though point is
is I haven't been back to the arena
since I was a young man fighting and so
uh we get there and
um it was already packed and I got there
um I mean right when this thing started
I think I got there I got the right when
the main card started so it's a little
different because on the prelim Zone had
two fights so I missed those two fights
then I got there right when uh the
women's catch weight fight happened uh
the Muay Thai fight with Jackie uh
Bunton and uh Martin so I was able to
see the entire uh main card ringside and
boy they it's just you got to see it man
Chan I'm Tony I've been to some big
events and this thing was super special
uh don't even get me start we'll get to
stamp we'll get to stamp but that's what
reminded me of like you know the old
Pride day is just a huge spectacle what
you loved and they have you know Matt
Hume who's heavily involved won
championship and they have uh some of
the staff from Pride that aids in the
production of one championship and boy
can you tell now I went to uh Pride back
in the day when Fedor fought uh Coleman
and it was good but I'm sure in Tokyo uh
in Japan stuff like that
um it's it's like the Tokyo dome is
probably a better event than what I saw
at the Thomas and Mack Center in Las
Vegas so they did what they can it was
solid but that wasn't better than the
UFC it just wasn't it was good but maybe
it's because they'd have all their
assets or whatever it just wasn't as
good as the UFC event now this one
um had a big fight feel the production
like I said was insane the screens and
then what they did which I thought was
uh smart I don't know who thought of
this on one championship's staff but
when you sat at your seat no matter if
you were cage side or at the very top in
the nosebleed sections everyone got a
bag and the bag had certain stuff in it
but the back had this uh wristband and
one Championship wristband and I was
like what and they're like oh do you
mind putting on I'm like yeah no problem
so I go you know my wife is with me my
coach who I got my black belt from them
all Easton and then my good buddy uh
Jeff suskin who's another black belt uh
it was me and those three and so they're
all like yo we'll put on The Wristband
so we put on The Wristband and I was
like what is this for and you gotta like
pull this little Tab out of it and then
it just freaking it would beat to the
they had it was connected to something
who'd beat during the main event and the
code like the big fights to their
walkout song it would like dance it was
nuts so when the arena is all black you
just see all these little
blue light's going boom boom boom boom
boom it was nuts man it was really smart
really really smart
um yeah the whole card was fantastic I
mean they didn't go head-to-head with
UFC but from top to bottom I mean they
start the UFC now just the way it goes
you know sometimes UFC's cards are
massive and exciting and then sometimes
they're boring sometimes one
championship fights are can be a little
slow and not exciting just so happened
this that particular weekend last
weekend the cars were aligned it's their
first big you know breaking ground in
the U.S soil fight card and it delivered
in every possible way except for the
main event but outside that dude it was
Sizzler so uh with rootolo and RDR we
love RDR here we've talked about RDR he
was the uh light heavyweight champ out
there in uh one championship and he did
just a jiu jitsu match against rootolo
who's a twin who's the Savage and he was
definitely under dogging this thing
definitely a bigger guy
here's my issue with that and you come
from a guy who kind of started this
trend so when you take an MMA fighter
who's good at Jiu Jitsu but they're not
Specialists like a rootolo brother who's
you know that's all he does he does not
do anything else but competitive Jiu
Jitsu at the highest level so RDR has
the challenge of just not getting
submitted but when you're trying to
you know entertain a crowd that's not
really the way to go it's just not they
could have done a bushesha RDR who does
do MMA and is an absolute Savage
background BJJ and he's bigger because
you know you're gonna get a finish there
with Rotolo being the smaller guy RDR
being the bigger guy
um you know it just it wasn't exciting
it's not what you're looking for you
know it's just not weird shout out to
RDR for not getting submitted my Rotolo
it's insane
um but either way all good
and this is what's interesting so we sit
down and there's a beautiful lady to uh
my or I'm uh yeah pop three seats down
uh taller lady and I'm like yeah where
do I know her from trying to think
because it's Denver right so I'm seeing
tons of people I haven't seen in years
I'm like where do I know where we're
from and then it hit me I'm like oh
that's Sage Northcutt sister oh and then
her husband is Raymond Daniels Colby I
think it's her name Colby but yeah yeah
Raymond Daniels who's you know uh
legendary uh human highlights The Human
Highlight and one of the best ever do it
and then they have a baby so they
brought their baby with him who looks
just like the dad they're cuter right
you know what I'm saying uh Daniel I
mean you want a cuter daughter than your
dad but if you can tell it is his kid
right so they're sitting there and I
didn't and I didn't think about him like
yeah Sage is on this card but that's
right when we first sat down and then
I'm sitting there right and then it uh
they bring up Sage's opponent and it's
that um Ahmed
um which isn't a favorable fight for
sage Sage been out three years remember
Sage literally got his face broken
against Cosmos literally face broken so
he's been out for three years she's
training with Team Alpha Male now
and they stand up and uh Daniels has his
baby he's like holding it and they have
the the you know the ear things on the
baby so it's so [__] loud and then uh
the the the sister she you can she's
like tearing up and I'm like oh [__] and
I look at my girl and she's like well
I'm like that's her brother fighting my
girl's like oh my God this is so intense
I'm like you
you got to pray to God right now Sage
it's gonna be a rough night I've sat
next to families when their family
doesn't win there's it will ruin our
night trust me and she's like oh my God
and my girl's never seen sage and he
comes out and looks like a goddamn
superhero like if Marvel was gonna make
a character and Sage went in for the
audition they're like this too spot on
what are we doing look at his body no
one looks like that his body was
ridiculous in person I was like dude
this is the best body I've ever seen it
was nachos again this fight was he he
was another not favorable for him so I
like my girl like this could be a long
night man this kid he's just been
managed wrong like his entire career has
been mismanaged he tracks every single
box you want out of a fighter great
looking kid right skills works his ass
off good person you have to worry about
you know getting DUIs or running to old
ladies in a carton you don't have to
worry about any of this good kid works
his ass off he's the Tim Tebow of
martial arts that's what he is and so
I'm telling my girl about him I'm giving
to the whole background she's like oh my
God I hope he wins I'm like me too and
then we looked over and the sisters
crying as he's walking out she's filming
she's crying and my girl starts to tear
up because she has a brother you know so
she's like I'm like oh my dear God Sage
please pull this off dude I'm talking to
Raymond Daniels I'm like hey man uh did
you help him out with this game I'm just
trying to like figure out I'm like did
you like help him out with the camp he
goes I mean I give him tips here and
there but no he's with Team Alpha Male
man you know so it's whatever they do
with him and I was like man I just feel
like this kid's been mismanaged and
Dan's like right I'm like this kid is a
superstar if you just give him the right
time to develop this kid's gonna be a
[__] Superstar I'm like I don't like
this fight for him and rain was like I
don't either man you know it's just
tough it is he's at the big league so
there's nothing we can do I'm like I
hope he wins
comes out
boom job first freaking 20 seconds those
jab knocks him on his ass like oh this
is terrible gets taken down I'm like
this is not good and then this little
Beautiful Bastard this
this jacked bastard gets him in this
heel hook and fish them in 40 seconds
man 40 what a night for sage Northcutt
look at this dude got got the win bonus
you know and then you know after this
you know the still his face isn't 100
percent
oh it's still healing no because I was
saying I was talking to sister I'm like
you know this is so good for him and you
know this and this and she's like yeah
you just got you know his face he's
gotta you know we're gonna hope that
heals 100 correctly so it kicked off
with uh Sage Northcutt with a ridiculous
submission did see that coming
then next up right the people I'm with
don't know won Championship so and I go
oh this next fight is my favorite fight
on the card this guy uh Soul ditch he's
the Croatian he's this huge huge uh free
agent the UFC tried going for him
everyone sent him an offer he decided to
sign who won championship and I've heard
Rumblings and how much he gets paid and
it's nuts so the one Championship
chachi's all in on this guy and then
he's fighting this uh
this dude's built like a praying mantis
and they're showing us highlights I'm
like damn this dude a bad mama jama this
dude and he called uh sold it out I'm
like this dude's a bad mama jama right
look dude he looks like a bad guy from
uh from a movie yeah yeah Bond or like
yeah like the old school like henchman
like European henchman you know he's
someone Leon Liam Neeson's gonna come
for he he took Liam Neeson's daughter
that's what he looks like so
soldiers comes out the the in the
intro's nuts it's very Crow cop-ish
right the the Croatian Flags it's going
he's walking I'm like this is the dude
here we go this is the guy I'm like I
guarantee this does not go to decision
I'm like my girl's like I gotta pee I'm
like don't go to the bathroom he's about
to knock his ass out you got to see this
and then as solicit is walking to the
the cage
your boy uh Kate Stam is pacing like a
lion but you know how most guys just do
their thing they're talking to coaches
he's facing like a lion at the zoo
staring on he he left his corner he he's
we're the walkout path is and he's
pacing back forth and we'll take his
eyes off of him so olich gets in the the
ring and he's getting in his face just
talking [__] I'm like damn this dude's
confident
first round happens
sawdish is very uh reliant on his left
hand he's just kind of throwing left not
setting up like I expect a little more
out of him here he's not really you know
the kicks not working there
um definitely you would watch on the
first round like oh Kate stems
outmatched there like he now granted
he's a 14-1 dog 14-1 that's how much
hype is on sold itch 14-1 and this is
really his first fight in one
Championship last fight was a DQ as a
mess so this is his first real fight the
Kate stand gets it's not 10-8 round but
you can tell like it's just a matter of
time for you it's knocked out second
round happens dude K Stam knocked him
out so bad I mean starched them and
everyone's like oh my god 14-1 dog 14-1
dog
knocked him out cold so it's tough you
know that's the fight business that's
why Vince McMahon goes I would never
invest in mixed martial arts because you
can't control the Stars like it's too
it's too easy to lose there's too many
ways to lose I would never you know
partake in that business and this is the
example like sold itch has all the
accolades has every reason to be world
champion the one Championship pays him
up the [__] Gazoo and then boom
knockout get starts stop bad to bad bad
he was out for a while bad bad
and my girl's in the cage she's never
seen this like Casey and she's like oh
my God I'm like yeah man I've been there
when I spend I'm talking about the guy
on the ground I've been there and I've
been a guy up top but I've been the guy
on the bottom and it is a rough go rough
go let's take a little break with all
the things going on in the fight World
cuz listen I only recommend products
that your boy personally uses I just
took a little shot here I'll leave one
here but in case of emergency I will
swallow this right now to the Kratom the
best Kratom on the planet this is the
sour apple this is the straight Kratom
to the brain shot right here the sour
apple I like the butterscotch myself but
listen if you haven't tried Kratom now
is the time but you gotta use it with a
brand that you trust a brand that I
asked to be on the shows because I
freaking use it every single day I'm
talking about happy hippo helps you
tackle your busy schedule helps you get
through life just helps you get stuff
done all right let's not give you some
crazy energy like a cup of coffee or
something like that no you're talking
about it's gonna just help you get in
that zone a good mood feeling all right
they're Kratom they they got gummies
powders the shots they got it all
whatever way you want to get the Kratom
into your body we got you covered you
can trust my friends that happy hippo
all right it's my Hidden Gem it's my
Limitless bill go to happyhippo.com
promo code is thick 23 thick with 3cs
you save 20 for Life use that code as
many times you want with your friends
family cousins co-workers whoever you
want share it happyhippo.com promo code
thick23 for the best creative on planet
Earth get you some happyhippo.com promo
code 23. now is the time kids on it is
doing their big old Semi-Annual Sale no
it's not Black Friday it's on its
semi-annual sale right now you get the
lowest prices on on its most popular
products I'm talking about for a limited
time to May 14th to be exact you get 25
off Alpha Brain temps off kettlebells
and up to 60 off on other products don't
wait too long because like I said the
sale ends May 14th alright so take
advantage of their on its Semi-Annual
Sale go to audit.com
and you get instant access to their
semi-annual deal right now all your
health and fitness Essentials don't miss
out on it's incredible sale and it's
going to go fast once they're sold out
they're out so get you some right now
you get 25 off bringing usually I'm
giving you guys 10 off but for the same
annual sale you get 25 off Alpha Brain
if you want to try the best nootropic on
planet Earth now is the time that's on
it.com for 25 off Alpha Brain tips off
kettlebells and up to 60 off other great
items it's on a Semi-Annual Sale get on
it right now audit.com shop let's get
back to the program
so then then the crowd here's what's
dope too because that one Championship
was crowd was educated because the the
the Applause for soldiers was nuts when
he lost his family like family and fan
base was over here and they were going
nuts nuts and but the whole crowd was
going nuts for sold itch I'm like damn
they know their stuff Sage I figured we
get a big Applause you know UFC guy came
over to the states I figured that once
when I heard the plaza sold itch I'm
like damn this educated crowd here we go
then stamp fair tax comes out now I
thought
stamp is only big in Asia you know
Thailand you know bro
it was like Conor McGregor walking on
that [__] everyone's on their feet
everyone's phones are out and uh I go to
Molly listen's like she's my favorite
I'm like you don't stand for today oh
dude she's my her walkouts are insane so
he gets out and he's like film it he's
52. and he's like filming like dude take
it easy dude so she comes out and my
girl's never see him she's like oh my
God she's so cute she's like doing you
know who she's doing her little dance
very tie dancing you know doing this
like K-pop dance cute little thing right
yeah and I'll and I've never seen her
like I know she dance and stuff but I'm
like oh she's a little too loosey-goosey
the girl she's fighting this American
Girl in in her corner is is uh Rose and
Pat Berry I'm like oh damn so she's
trained properly right
yeah yeah yeah so uh uh Elise Anderson
so stamp comes out I'm like gosh
hopefully she [__] Gets In the Zone
here and so she's doing her dancing
doing her dancing and then she because
we were right by where they enter the
the cage so she's doing her dancing
she's all smiling like cute little thing
I'm like God damn this girl cannot get
any killer she's doing her thing and
then it but she stops the dancing and
her face goes from zero to 100. Boom I'm
like oh damn like a mall who loves her
was like oh I wish I didn't see that
that was not I'm like what'd you think
dude you can dance all the way up to the
[__] cage so once the dance the intro
stop she's all business gets in that
cage first round they're going back and
forth stamp had this ridiculous
transition when she takes her back for a
Muay Thai girl high level [__] takes her
back round ends there
second round starts dude she hits her
with this this body kick and her coaches
go her ribs are broke it hits her it
looked bad I mean it's full you couldn't
kick it back harder like her technique
the full-blown you see her hip every
Waka you can hear it and that girl's
done done so's and then the the the
Applause damn fear text got it would
blow you I was like holy legit Superstar
she
I mean rotain probably got the biggest
uh uh Applause but Stanford takes right
there man Superstars and I thought they
were just speaking in Asia I was like
yeah I bet the crap I'm like oh she's
cute no no no no so they're chanting her
name like a [__] and then Mike
uh Mikey our boy Mikey mushumeshi who's
on firing the kid who absolutely adore
he comes out
and again because that first Jiu Jitsu
match with RDR and Rotolo I'm like oh
hopefully this isn't one of those boring
things man but this I I would say
stamp and raw Tang definitely biggest
Applause I'd say the crowd was mainly a
Mikey crowd they they knew his whole he
does that he does this they were all
doing that they're chanting his name
everyone's tuned in
he just never gave Osama a chance like
he was constantly attacking his legs
when he came out for the thing he was
just giving him his leg like go ahead
see what happens and it was like this
octopus just listen I've been doing just
to what 16 years on my black belt I
don't know what the [__] that I I don't
know it's not my the world I came from
it's a what those kids are doing is just
it's different I'm playing Tecmo ball
these kids are playing the new Madden
online with each other talking [__] I'm
playing techno ball still like I I don't
know what it's going on down there and
he he would go for a submission and it
wouldn't get it and be closed and
finally got him finally freaking got him
uh with a rear naked choke but that that
crowd was nuts nuts for men nutsos
nutsos and Rod tank came out he's
fighting this Edgar uh Tiberius tabaris
who's a Mexican world champion and my
girl's Mexican is [__] right so she's
like oh I'm going for him like all right
[__] good luck and uh Rod Tang you know
he's been whatever 400 something fights
just I was like man he looks like he
doesn't want to be here he's just he'd
kick him just do his thing came do his
thing and then he would throw a cake
every time he threw a kick that Mexican
Muay Thai Fire would do a spin
basketball and it's close it's like
right across his face I'm like that
ain't good this this keeps going on he's
gonna land that
rotating with a thousand fights seen it
before doing a thing doing a thing that
he knows what's exactly coming it's in
the the second round he throws that kick
the dude goes through the spin elbow
this [__] catches it like the
Matrix catches it same arm elbow boom
knockout like God dog
the whole crowd chanting raw Tang raw
Tang he he can't even do the interview
they're shouting Rod tank so much they
can't get through the interview and the
the announcer's just waiting and they
can't the crowd's so
hyped up off this knockout chanting
rotating you're talking about legit
Superstars man legit Superstars so you
have that all going on
finally the main event comes I'm like
that was the long-ass card Main Event
comes I'm like let's go DJ and it was it
was just mainly great you know we have
two high-level athletes like that and
they're trying to implement a game plan
sometimes this happens happen a little
bit in the UFC main event with uh
Sterling cejudo which we'll get to but
with Demetrius Johnson who thinks he's
the and he's right he thinks he's the
best in the world at in the clinch uh
and Adrian Adriano Mirage being the
bigger guy he beat him up and they
clinch the only problem with that it
does it just doesn't make for an
exciting fight for the fans but DJ
definitely you know dominated the fight
won the fight you know won the fight it
just I think the standard was set so
high because look at that you have
submission and nothing goes past the
second round nothing
submission submission TKO KO from stamp
fair tax submission by Mikey mushumeshi
uh ridiculous cable by Rod tang and the
main event and you get to you know so
people are just like come on like
there's just like there's like blood in
the air it's like come on it just wasn't
happening at that high level just
sometimes that happens but DJ looked
great DJ looked great got it done uh
altitude was not an issue for him I
think attitude was an issue from Rise
but DJ got it done man and that was this
last one I don't think so because he was
like they're like what about and they
mentioned some guy he was like yes show
me the money
I don't think it's last one yeah he
asked the crowd too it's like yes want
me to do one more there was like no then
Rod tank was like yeah he wants to go up
the the guy who's uh the world champion
the the weight class up he's like I'd
like to go there and the guy's massive
wow massive but just from top to bottom
but you know Main Event happens but
other than that my God it was Unreal one
of the best events I've ever been to
Fantastic absolutely so impressed man so
damn impressed it was a good time
great time so I flew back because we had
fight companion calabas fight campaign
for UFC 288 which on paper is a great
card our boy Matt farola the
Steamrollers should have been on the
main card I kept saying that and I think
you'd be you know
it's tough because where do you put them
you would probably put them uh to kick
the main card off over chrome Gracie
because I don't think we realized Chrome
Gracie was like wait it's not 1994. and
no one's like no you you gotta Advance
your skills dude you just can't have
zero striking expect someone to jump
into your guard you know it's it's just
not it's not the Hoist Gracie taste dude
the game he's been off three years
that's how fast this game evolves he's
been off three years thought he he's so
damn Jitsu he can go no wrestling no
striking no there's not a JuJu player in
the world who's going to win a UFC fight
just based off the YouTube never gonna
happen those days are over now if you're
a wrestler you can get it done striking
depend on the right matchup could
probably get it done outside that not
happening dude you can't just be a Jitsu
guy and win fights in the UFC on any
level near C
the 100th ranked guy at the at the
Federal Way division is going to beat
you he's more well-rounded he can't
avoid those that Jiu Jitsu especially if
you don't have a takedown Arsenal as far
as even a single leg a trip if you don't
have any of that and you expect them
just to come to you what are we doing
here what are we doing you know uh it
was just tough that kind of set the tone
for the main card
set the tone for the main card
problem is when the when the card's this
long and drawn out you know five
decisions in a quick K 1 KO from Jan
over Jessica and Josh was so ridiculous
KO
um it just you know it just doesn't make
for a fun card it was just a long kind
of drawn out boring night the New Jersey
fan base was not having it you know
because again the Matt our boy
Steamroller set the tone
starts Drew Dober dude a guy who has a
Hall of Fame first first battle Hall of
Fame Granite chin if the granite chin
Hall of Fame he's in there especially
right now he's top five and gets
starched man with with what 52 seconds
left in the first round so that set the
tone you know and he lives nearby so
everyone's all crunk about that
um
so it just makes it tough and for Matt
you know we we have them on the show and
you know he wants Patty pimlet next
hopefully Patty's uh injury is healed
with ankle surgery and that fight
happens because that has main car
written all over it especially if aljo's
gonna fight in August and Boston against
sugar Shawn put Matt and uh Patty on the
great card that might be too soon for
Patty so if I'm a steamroller I'm
waiting to November or something like
that to make sure I get that Patty fight
because that's a big fight dude big
fight great fight too tough fight for
Matt tough fight for Patty great fight
great fight with two Young Bucks trying
to become world champion so take my
money
um you know and then also with the
coming event with Muhammad Gilbert Burns
uh I told you guys take the dogs so
Steamroller won
um Muhammad one Al Joe one so told you
take the dogs but with uh Muhammad
Gilbert Burns you could tell that
Gilbert was
um compromised his left hand I don't
know when it happened has he said
anything about it what round had
happened but you know a lot of it uh you
can credit Muhammad through the kicks
completely taken away Gilbert Burns best
tool his left hook those kicks
neutralize that so he couldn't throw it
was the kicks from Muhammad the reason
he broke his hand I would probably
um assume so
but again that was just
so McGregor says very poor about it's
not a poor about this is this is the
problem because
for Muhammad he's fighting again Gilbert
Burns who's an absolute Savage and he he
kind of dominated now it's not Gilbert's
or it's not Muhammad's fault or Gilbert
was not Muhammad's fault that Gilbert
broke his hand matter of fact it's
probably due to him throwing those kicks
and the the way he was fighting so let's
say uh
once I was causing heavy bruising and
redness to spread
yeah I mean so it's due to kicks that's
part of fighting you know so that's a
great job by Muhammad and man did he
cement himself to be the next one get a
tall shot at 170. there's no way that
you can discipline
balel Muhammad
after this fight you just can't it's not
his fault that Gilbert was compromised
matter of fact the reason he's
compromised because of the training and
execution of Muhammad nobody else could
get it done and Gilbert's been on this
you know this great streak and he
stopped him straight in his tracks
Dominic five rounds maybe give one round
to Gilbert probably a shutout for
Muhammad so there's no way shape or form
can you rob Muhammad of the next title
shot I bet he'll be the you know the
reserve for Leon Edwards and Kobe County
now if you're cold and you're watching
this y'all thank God because if Muhammad
went out there and you know uh knocked
him out in 15 seconds you're gonna have
a lot of pressure on Dana to give
Muhammad the next fight that didn't
happen so it's a huge win for Kobe that
night probably the biggest winner to be
honest Muhammad did his job he just
didn't do it in a way that we can demand
that he fights with the next title you
just can't it's such I know it's so
[__] up it's such a bummer but he did
enough where he he's guaranteed the next
title shot
yeah depending how that goes depending
when it's scheduled uh listen don't put
it past in or make him fight one more
though
that's the shame that's what's the real
shame maybe another one after that so it
said uh he had a tear in his shoulder I
think it was in the first Gram on the
ground when he took him down
he's got a tear yeah so shoulder injury
well so he had a tear from his shoulder
during a scramble well that scramble
happened because Muhammad yeah so that's
part of fighting that's good I'm
Muhammad
says checking the shoulder tomorrow
hoping no surgery yeah how can you not
love Gilbert Burns man such a good dude
but for Muhammad just like I hope
they'll make him fight another one
stinkaway did for the UC stepped up
after Ramadan two weeks notice fights
Gilbert Burns beats him shut out and and
it's just the world we live in the fans
like I don't know man like what look at
his resume there's no one more deserving
the Top Shot than Muhammad what the f
are we doing if that doesn't speak for
itself
what do you want to do a tick tock dance
a slap fight competition what the [__]
you want this guy to do your title shot
it's insane but the biggest win of the
night would be probably Kobe Covington
now there's no pressure to see Muhammad
fight Leon Edwards it's such a bummer
but he did cement himself hopefully
they'll make him fight again you never
know Coleman event I'm sorry Main Event
Al Joe Henry sahuto
um
you know I I think this was a case of
just you know two of the highest level
guys uh Hennessy were taking three years
off I thought he came out a little slow
um but I just think aljo's just a better
fighter he beat him across the board uh
anybody who you know makes a living off
critiquing fighting had aljo win in the
fight chin did not and Chin uh glasses
are foggy and have a good angle let's
just be honest you don't have a good
angle still have him during the fight
companion you just have bad angle and
that's okay I'm not gonna you know still
got your job I have something for you
too after that okay perfect perfect
um but I here's here's the other bummer
so for uh Vallejo Mohammed and aljo who
both don't get enough credit in this
fight business for aljo
you know he's getting booed by a New
Jersey crowd at the end of the fight
because sugar Shawn's such a star people
want to see that
um so now the narrative isn't that algo
be one of the best combat sport athletes
of all time maybe the best it's
the antics of sugar Shawn and his boy
marab taking his jacket with that
shit-eating grin when he got his jacket
that was so funny but I think it's good
you know we are going to get streaks of
WWE and Enos with the you know with them
uh kind of being co-partners now or
Partners now in the same business so I
like you know sugar Shawn jump in the
ring give him the promo build the fight
up now we know what's coming up next I
like I love all that uh you know sugar
is doing a post-fight interview even
though he didn't fight talking about the
fight it just builds up Al Joe and sugar
even more I don't
and maybe he doesn't kill maybe he
doesn't care like Muhammad is like this
New Jersey crowd sucks Algos like this
crowd sucks you know they kind of turn
on them they're just they're just
unfulfilled the entire card screwed both
those gentlemen over who don't get
enough credit already so for for aljo
you know I told you guys after this
fight the narrative no matter how it
goes whether he knocked him out in 13
seconds or being by decision which he
did I thought
oh man I would give for sure one round
of cerudo I can see two no more than two
not a chance you have more than two
either way aljo beat him pretty
convincingly but even I told you guys
that's still not enough to satisfy those
haters of aljo or mohabbit in this case
but for aljo because they go ah so who
does old man three years off not the
same guy okay okay what if I took him
down four times you guys have been taken
down once prior to this taken out four
times you know this is a case of
Henderson Henderson one of the greatest
ever do it alja's been working for the
past three years only get better he's
gotten better since those Peter yon
fights Corey sander Hagin fights TJ
Dillashaw he's getting better every
single he's in his prime so I think this
was not the case of Henry sudo being
older I think it's the case of how
[__] good algo is and you guys need
to recognize that it's but this isn't
gonna do it I knew this wasn't gonna do
it despite the crowd this could have
been in Vegas this could have been Al
Joe's you know Grandma's backyard
doesn't matter the fan base was not
going to give him his credit so now he's
gonna get sugar Shawn which is actually
a more favorable matchup than James I
would say I'll just probably gonna be a
two to one favorite at least
that won't do it because then the
narrative there's gonna make sure he has
no wrestling
so I don't know what it's going to take
they might have to it might take
probably in a year out from now for aljo
to step up and fight at 145 and fight
volkanovsky so if he beats volkanoski
will that satisfy you guys does he have
to do that does he have to beat the
pound-for-pound number one guy in the
world it might be Jon Jones a lot of
people that still have voknowsky does it
have to be does he have to beat
volkanovsky in order to get your respect
it's crazy to me crazy
the Emory committee is insane to me uh
strong open Lots been in favor jumped
out minus there you go two one two one
favorite called it
yeah stylistically now I'm not saying
sure you can't win this fight trigger
striking is a lot better than uh
Sterling's more diversity more tools
very rangy it's like a Mac Truck he
leads guys in you know so there's
definitely a route where I can see uh
sugar Shawn winning this fight but to
that being said it's stylish it's a very
very tough fight for sugar
very much so
um
favors aljo just Styles it's just the
way it goes at this level but I know
it's gonna take for Aldo to get the
respect it's so hilarious to me it's
just never gonna happen
but again the star of this card
besides uh sugar Sean and uh marab who
do you even fight would be Steamroller
yeah has to be and he got the bonus
so we'll see man but overall not a card
that we're gonna remember
that's the shame
what are you watching yeah because of
the last two fights but um so yeah I was
wondering like am I tripping when I saw
that you know I thought that not like
dominated at all I'm saying just barely
edged it out so I looked at you know
verdict MMA which I talked about before
it just it tallies up a score of people
like media and just fans and everyone
around the world so they
they I think they said it was the
closest ever
yeah this was one of the closest title
fights ever on verdict and Henry hudo
had a higher final score with a
differential of just 0.14
and I remember I was honest with you
like I don't judge fights round by round
which is exactly how you're supposed to
judge UFC fights that's the way it works
I just look at who I thought actually
won the fight as a whole like you know
one Championship let's have one
Championship which I lost which I like
yeah I actually like I look at it so
that's why I kind of had Henry yeah
you're wrong but I know I'm just saying
but it's interesting that verdict the
they got this whole score so it's not
sound like a you know it was so close it
was just super super close yeah I I you
know I don't think anybody you know was
robbed you know what I'm saying it's not
one of those fights we're like oh hey
not one of those you know
um I just want to see if I was tripping
if I was like am I seeing this correctly
because I just really I can see if you
don't have an untrained eye and you're
drinking I can see how you got there
definitely both the glasses are all
[__] up glasses drinking all that
stuff it didn't sway you when domic
cruise is the greatest 135 of all time
who's like uh no both because you guys
are you guys are you know your
experience for Fighters Dominics is and
that's his job too as an analyst you've
done analyst stuff too as well so I
remember when I was when Dom said bye to
me he's like hey man nice to meet you
but you're crazy
he's right I mean he's the analyst he's
actually looking picking everything
apart if Dom would have been like I
think so who don't want to fight you
know he's he fights on 135 is when the
greatest ever do it he's a professional
ass I've been like I need to I need to
sober up then man I'm just off on this I
I would you know if Dom says I'm like
damn I need I really need to get my [__]
together but when he even co-signed that
aljo he was like this is easy aljo he's
like both judging you'd never know but
he's like I have Al Joe and I'm like
thank God thank God so I'm not gonna and
Jude and shout out to Dominic Cruz man
hell yeah dude dude how bad ass is you
guys don't understand the stress I was
under so I land in Denver and going
through my head I've been so busy but
you know we have a Booker for the show
and so it was going to be Ryan Garcia
and George Janko and you know George
doesn't know UFC at all in any facet he
might watch some of the big ones here
and there but he'll know fine at all
George could you know talk the air off
of a wall he didn't just talk he's a
great person to throw things off of and
he'll keep the conversation going he's
great at podcasting and I I love the
kids so we had George on there and he's
just you know it's like having a
Comic-Con who doesn't know fighting
they're just there for entertainment and
then I was thinking about like I got
Ryan Garcia who also doesn't watch MMA
this is look at the car I'm like it's
gonna be a slow I assume it's gonna be a
slower card there's a lot that's going
on in the world of UFC especially at the
Banta weight division especially in the
welterweight division there's a lot to
untangle here these two don't know [__]
about fighting I need something that
fourth chair because originally was just
new three of us I was like I need
somebody that four chair who I can
bounce off of and you know argue with me
or debate me on what's going to happen
next and break down the fight and then
uh you know Don recruits came to my mind
I thought there's no way they're not
using Dom during this weekend it's 1 35
he's probably up to his [__] ears and
breaking down and analyzing this fight
and then uh my Booker Tom goes no dude
he just posted a video giving picks it
looks like he's at home in San Diego so
tax him yo man you around he's like
what's up like how fast can you get to
La he's like what's up I'm like dude I'm
doing a fight command show he's like let
me look at it and I'm like no way and
then uh probably like and I'm like oh
come on Dom let's do this hour later
goes ah man see you soon I'm like oh
hell yeah and I go ETA nothing hour goes
by nothing
at six o'clock show starts live at seven
Ryan Garcia texts me dude boy did I mess
up flight complication not gonna make it
there by seven dude I'm so sorry I'm
like dude we go live and now he's like
I'm so sorry dude I'm just not gonna be
able to make it I'm like okay okay so
I'm like all right well that's just me
and George you can't do a show I'm gonna
have to cancel the show and then I text
Dom ETA question mark with like a face
like you know The Emoji's like and then
30 minutes goes by and he goes I'll be
there right around 7 20. I'm like you
are goddamn Saint sir you saved the day
you couldn't be a better person to have
on thank God for dominant Cruz I said I
owe you man because I don't know what
you're gonna owe me but yeah when I need
something I'm gonna hit you up that's
from San Diego not just to LA but
Calabasas which is a freaking dream dude
and he did it oh dude Lifesaver and Dojo
he brought Dojo yeah his dog yeah
brighten up everyone's day dude the best
oh I owe them save the day dude
absolutely love them and I told you guys
too like me and Dom were you know we've
worked together before many years uh at
Fox that always put us together when I
was bringing down stuff on Fox and me
and Dom would always Clash a little bit
not not nothing mean but just our
opinions on fights and stuff like that
and we'd butt heads and so there wasn't
like chemistry there you know because
Dom's a fiery dude but man that dude you
want to have somebody that's worked on
themselves I know he's doing therapy or
what how nice is Dominic Cruz he's the
coolest man now he's a don't get it
twisted he's a Savage I've heard this
he's the combo he's the Kobe mentality
where he will rip your [__] throat
off but he's just worked on himself so
much and that comes out when he's
analyzing fights and he's such a
mastermind of the game just the way he
thinks about things like his opinion I'm
sure it's gonna be one of the clips uh I
was like man how do you feel about Al
Joe and murab not wanting to fight each
other he goes I don't understand that
he's like I'd love to fight my teammate
think about it he's like think about it
the the only other person in the world
that they can bring to fight is a guy
that my brother that I'm working that
means we're doing something right he's
like that's like uh that'd be such an
honor man that we get to fight each
other nobody knows each other better be
so cool I'm like that's such a good
perspective man when back in the day I
figured like you'd he'd be like oh I'll
fight my mom you know what I'm saying
but he just breaks it down so
brilliantly you know he's so he's so
good man so shot Donna Cruz I owe you
buddy I owe you how you doing brother
what a freaking wind dog I don't want to
say it's good luck when you come on the
show but I'm just saying dude I'm just
saying
yeah yeah just got to keep keep coming
on man uh it was yeah it was Unreal and
uh it's still honestly sinking in yeah
cause you're talking about a guy and we
talked about this uh last week before
your fight it's like Drew Dober is this
absolute Savage who hits like a Mack
truck and obviously so do you but you
have to you know be smart about it you
don't want to play that game and uh I
mean we were you know we did the Cowboys
fight companion but we only do the main
card
and so like we got here early to watch
your fight and it just set the the boys
all of us were jumping around man we
were so happy for you I was just happy
because I didn't imagine it going like
that that quick I thought for sure
you're gonna win put money I need to win
but I didn't think you'd go down like
that you know it was it was nuts man
yeah honestly I I was you know honestly
I was planning on wrestling him but uh I
was I was doing well with the Striking I
you know I saw his nose busted up like I
busted his nose up right away and then
uh you know even even like when I was in
there
um I knew I was Landing but I knew I was
whiffing on some punches too
um but you know I threw some kicks I got
some these off and I was doing well on
the feet so I was just keeping it
standing and dober's a dude too who's
known for his chin my man like Dover can
take a hit
yeah man you know I had to remind
everyone about this F-bomb
that freaking F-bomb bro uh I tell you
what I bet you the UFC this morning in
the whole marketing uh meeting this
morning like we should have put the
steamroller on the main event the main
card we did we that main car could have
used it man that main card was I mean
you were the highlight of the card but
by far the entire card like the rest the
that main event man was you know and
there's no disrespect anybody on the on
the main card but it's a bit of a it was
a long one bro especially for someone
working it it was a long slow card and
that that's how I mean aljo could beat
anybody in the world that way he could
strangle anybody or he could go out
there wrestle and out point in no Aldo
he's like healthy now like he's he's
very good at like you know he winning
you know he's he's a competitor and he
wins yeah he won yeah I'm gonna get to
Al Joe I want to stay on you for a
second because after you get that insane
knockout then he call out Patty pimlet
which I think you know anybody who's
following you and has spoken to you and
you know on Twitter you we figured that
was going to come my only caveat with
that is he is he's gonna be out for do
we know when he's gonna come back love
the fight hope they give it to you it's
my only thing is like is it actually
possible
yeah definitely I mean he had that ankle
surgery I think he'll be ready by the
end of the year I mean best case
scenario November MSG you know me and
Patty on that main card pay you oh um
but if he needs if he needs uh December
Vegas you know that that doesn't sound
too bad either
I think would you jump across the Pod
and fight him in his own backyard too
a hundred percent man that I would love
to go to London and fight him there I
think that would be so cool going going
like you know uh like enemy territory
you know I got a lot of love in London
as well I bet um but it would be so cool
to go there never been oh it's great man
and then also
um you know it seems like it could be a
possibility too if you're talking about
that kind of time frame with his ankle
but he also replied on uh Twitter was
like yeah let's do it he's like it's
gonna be the easiest route to get into
the top 15 I was like yes I don't know
about that Patty uh bro but I don't I
don't blame him man I even you look at
the top 15 of the lightweight Division
and I mean you know I I mean anyone
anybody could beat anybody on any given
day and uh you know I think me and him
will just have such an exciting fight
you know I know I know I know I'm human
as well you know you know anybody could
get knocked out and I know that I might
hey I could beat anybody in the world
all I need is the opportunity and I
think Styles make fights and uh you know
me and Patty like we'll go we'll throw
on the feet and then I'll grapple with
him too man I like I love Jiu Jitsu
eventually I want to use my Jiu Jitsu
and show my you know my wrestling again
I was planning on doing that with Dober
but uh you know we're not gonna do this
out man so you can show them Jiu-Jitsu
skills
yeah but I think uh you know and me and
Dominic Cruz talking about this on the
fight campaign when you look at really
about 185 and under maybe even 170 and
under 1 through 15. it's all about who's
gonna be Champion it's all about
matchups and styles because anyone one
through 15 can be world champion all you
guys have the skill set to do it
yeah I know that's why it's it's an
exciting Division and uh dude I'm just
so pumped to you know be in the mix now
you know I think that everybody knows
that you know I show up to fight and
always put on exciting fights and that
you know I have the power that I can
knock out anybody in the world how how
did you celebrate
Saturday night
uh when right went up to the suite my
friends and family all had a suite there
was like 40 people in the suite and uh
watch watch the rest of the fights watch
aljo get it done and then you know was
walking around the stadium and just
seeing everyone it was like I was
getting mauled
um
I was out there it was like the first
time my mom my one buddy was trying to
act like my security yeah yeah yeah yeah
you'll notice the one friend just kind
of takes charge you're like oh damn this
is how it's going to go now huh and then
they start becoming your manager it's
weird dude it's a weird transition yeah
it was so cool but I got so much love
from you know the people in New Jersey
and uh so many people came out to the
fights it was it was it was an unreal
moment yeah it was a good night for your
your entire Camp man and like I said was
there pressure setting the tone you know
and you set the tone in a major major
way and you know unfortunately that New
Jersey crowd was a little rough you know
a little rough they want more excitement
they won five uh kind of performances
like you had that's what they wanted on
the main card main card was a little
slow and then with Al Joe
I thought it was interesting because you
know again I'm drinking I only had one
glass of whisk usually I have to watch
fight over because I get a little drunk
on those companions but this one I was
good I was paying attention watching
with Dominic Cruz and who's a perfect
person to watch it with and we both
scored it pretty easily for Al Joe and
you know that one judge who gave it to
Henry you know insane you know there's
there's been really across the board as
far as like people in my space like the
analysts or experts quote unquote almost
everyone gives it to aljo it's not that
controversial
yeah you know it was a close competitive
fight and you really got to go you know
round by round
um but every round was you know pretty
competitive but you know aljo won that
fight aljo beat him and uh you know it's
on to the next now dude how about aljo
Landing takedowns
yeah yeah is that statistic uh Henry
coming into this fight in his entire
career has been taken down once I think
by uh Demetrius Johnson
I think aljo looked deception Al Joe as
far as the if the company strike numbers
go took him down four I think he had
four takedowns
which are the countless takedowns nuts
that's the Phantom like that's the
Bantam white goat now dude he's looking
good and he got to his back like that's
what I had Dominic Cruz Break the fight
down he was like you know if we know how
good aljo is on the back Henry knows so
he's not gonna allow that to happen I
don't think he's allowed to happen I
said well to to kind of piggyback on
that is aljo so special at taking the
back it doesn't matter if Henry knows
it's coming he can't stop it and that's
what happened it just shows you the
skill level of algem and he looked he
looked phenomenal and I you know I know
people want lockouts and stuff like that
but that was a very strategic win over
you know one of the best Combat Sports
athletes of all time if not the best
yeah and then you know that's why you
know he's the best in the world in that
position and just his grappling is so
high level but his fight IQ you know and
the the thing he's just he fought five
rounds and he's like not hurt you know
he's he's like he's good he's healthy
and like I mean me being in there it's
like every time I get out of a fight I'm
healthy it's like I mean I'm blessed I'm
already blessed but uh I'll do like like
Al Joe getting like 25 minutes fighting
to Judo and being healthy and with a
victory that's a blessing man and it's
it's on to the next and his cardio
looked insane too
oh yeah man he's he's prepared you know
he's he's a champion of the world and he
knows what he has to do to prepare for a
fight and he does it that's what we do
and and uh you know it's uh we're it's
it's nice and what do you what do you
think of the the post-fight Antics with
sugar Shawn coming into the octagon and
then Rob checking his jersey jacking his
jacket and uh it was kind of Rob was
kind of the star of the show it was so
funny man it was so funny I loved it Rob
looked good in that jacket and you know
Rob is Rob is the [__] man like uh
like just uh always always there you
know like when I was warming up and
stuff he's like massaging me and just
like chopping my back and like he's just
so he's just like brother go out there
do your best yep do your best like like
thank you yeah that's that's what I'm
gonna do yeah that's all you close team
man you can tell you you guys got a
close-knit team
yeah yeah it's uh yeah I'm gonna go into
the gym tonight see everyone I'm I'm
pumped man and I'm pretty healthy too
you know my hand's a little messed up my
wrist but uh I think I'm I think I'm
good man yeah you're good ready to go
here you know you'll be good to go now
Dana did mention maybe sugar Shawn and
Al Joe fight and I think it was November
if that's right in November in Boston
wow that would be sick that'll be sick
so I I could see a patty pimlet
Steamroller Boston going down too man
Boston be a fun place to fight
pay-per-view Al Joe Main Event yeah
yeah that's a big boy that's a big boy
man
uh that would be sick yeah I mean that's
definitely I'm I'm pumped uh for that
fight I hope we we get that made and uh
and you know it'll be a fun fun build up
you know like I love Barstool I'll try
to get out to Barstool yeah
we do some fun stuff for the promotion I
was always telling the uh Robbie Foxx
that uh you know bar still does a rough
and rowdy and I had my brother the
cheese roll I fought on rough and rowdy
oh that's right I knew that that's right
and I was I was like we got to do uh
Ultimate Fighter like Ross and Rowdy out
do like team Strong Island I'll get a
bunch of my Long Island Hardo buddies
I'll train them up in boxing he'll get a
bunch of scousers that'd be cool
that'd be sick
hell yeah yeah well hopefully you don't
have a fight coming up too soon man so
we gotta get you out to LA get you on a
companion we'll look at the schedule
we'll get you out here man be fun real
quick yeah August 19th is the targeted
time for 292 for O'Malley versus uh oh
August 19th August 19th and then they're
saying or there was four or 15 takedowns
for algeme
if you guys landed four takedowns out of
15 tries oh yeah four but he did land
officially four takedowns in the August
14th and August 14th is 19th 19th that's
in Boston
yeah looks like it that'll work
yeah maybe I
think it's probably too soon but we'll
see I'll just say that's too soon for
Patty
yeah yeah yeah and probably be too soon
and there's no rush either man you know
enjoy enjoy the win get back to training
get better get the tools going you're
not hurt you know yeah you know next man
up you know I know nazim will get a
fight soon hopefully International fight
week hopefully you know I could get out
to Vegas for that and uh Billy Q will be
up you know soon enough yeah again you
guys whole Squad man you're busy yeah
Billy Q's a beast too man
yeah he is man and it was it was awesome
you know having them out in my corner
all fight week you know and then I'm
always with him every fight week and we
just Crush her you know we crush the
weight cut the weight cut the fight week
went like perfectly smooth you know it's
like we we know we know how to do this
now you know and uh and we're enjoying
like you know every step of the way I
always got my dad my brother everybody's
just running around the fighter Hotel
like having a good time
um yeah that's a cool man what are you
gonna do with are you what do you you're
a smart guy with your money got the the
50k bonus what do you plan to do with
that bad boy
we'll see you know I told my wife we can
decorate the house now you know we just
renovated everything got a new kitchen
in it's looking nice there man
granite counter there
oh the bulldozer is that a bulldozer
what's up Pops
hey man still living on cloud nine oh I
bet yeah there's nothing better there's
nothing and he's not not only did he get
the win he got the bonus and he's not
injured there's nothing better as a
family member man hey three knockout
three first round knockout yeah we're
going Sizzler pops we're going Sizzler
man dude dad got some big ass dick
beaters on him too dude your dad got the
big mitts on him man
those are the original f-bombs
you saw from the tree
I love it man and then where's Big
Cheese roller at
all right yeah he's working but he'll be
back here soon what do you do for work
uh we uh my dad started construction
companies so now my brother kind of
takes over love it and you guys are so
strong island this is yeah so if I was
writing a sitcom I'd write it after you
guys
yes we live right uh right on the water
in uh in Long Island in the bay
and uh we get we get it popping like
every summer here we got the boats and
stuff
oh damn dude you're doing it right
yeah we got the jet skis in the water
damn
Chin's mouth is Salvage he wants to
murder some fish out there you guys you
guys got to uh come come to Long Island
dude that's not a bad idea I'll book a a
venue out there and get out there man
uh the Paramount the Paramount we're in
Huntington I saw like Tim Dillon there
uh uh Jim Brewer there the big boy it's
a six spot yeah that'd be dope man yeah
well enjoy your time I'm sure you're
making all the rounds you're making all
the rounds I'm sure all the media wants
to get a hold of that beautiful red
beard of yours
yeah talking I'm talking a live man
after after this and then talking to
hawani and then bizbing oh man you you
you only only uphill from here my man
you started here and you're one of the
big boys I know shit's crazy yeah you
deserve it brother you deserve it man
and you're a good person and fans can
can feel it you know so this is just the
start for you man I'm so excited for you
you're a [__] good dude you deserve
this man and we're gonna get you out
here let's hopefully your fight didn't
get announced like too soon you know
because the summer it's gonna be a
steamroller summer man we're gonna get
you to LA and flex that those red
muscles
yeah I appreciate that man I can't wait
to get out there yeah brother have a
have a great day man you deserve it try
and stop and smell the roses a little
bit man you know
okay don't worry I'm smelling it yeah
brother tell your dad I said uh bye and
uh keep those hands you know in the
chamber there dude
all right thanks bro have a good one
have a good one man I'll hit you up
later
brother what do you got Jen
um all right let's start with
I thought George was fantastic yeah
George is asking you know the common fan
questions when usually you know we
usually have Brian for that but you know
George was asking questions because
sometimes I make the mistake and you
know everyone has holes in the way they
do shows or uh analysts I'm So Into the
weeds because you know I fought in the
OC and I know a lot about mixed martial
arts where I'll just go from point A to
point F where George is like hold on
let's go back to a like and he and Dom's
like I like this man it's rare I get
asked these questions like me too
and if it's Brian doing we light them up
right we're like you piece because he
can handle it we're like you piece of
[__] you know but with George like good
question man by the way shout out to
George because he he did his homework he
brought in no cards he came around an
hour early and had colored note like
what the [__] is that he's like I'm
gonna give my analysis get he was
because I haven't seen these guys fight
and I I researched him before I came out
I'm like props to him for that that's
why you're gonna be successful dude
because most people show up like what am
I watching you know you're like ah God
damn dude and then I have to discuss in
uh my fan base already knows most of it
but George was great yeah he's fun nice
guy yeah
uh all right so the first one is I
didn't realize this happened over the
weekend but Roy Nelson
I don't know if he was retired or not
but he actually did a bare Knuckle Event
and of course he he jacked up the dude
who is this from game who the hell wants
to fight Roy Nelson bare Knuckles and
this is It's called Game Bird bare
knuckle MMA so this is obviously Jorge
Mazda's organization but so you do bare
knuckle but you can also do MMA as well
so it's not just stand up oh so this
wasn't just like uh bkfc no no like they
can actually grapple too basically UFC
but bare knuckle I mean Roy Nelson's
gonna go undefeated I know because of
that right perfect it's like a Mack
truck can't take him down if you do take
him now you got a world of problem
and this is from capos's Twitter
Roy looked exactly the same
is Built For This
that's Robin blocked oh our boy Robin
Black's the commentator
makes you like this even more
[Music]
oh
god dog
yeah
very very Tank Abbott Vibes there yeah
totally old school stuff yeah but uh
Baron Oklahoma good luck beating
freaking Roy Nelson bare knuckle good
luck
indeed also the fight over the weekend I
didn't watch it but Canelo Alvarez
fought John Ryder and of course he
destroyed him his decision United's
decision but uh yeah these are minus
2000 favorite
yeah so it should have destroyed him for
sure his his walkout was dope probably
you know they're saying a lot because
one Championship was over the weekend
but his wife got probably the best
you'll see insane Canela he can always
walk out his nuts he he fights the Cinco
de Mayo weekend
oh yeah so I I heard that he also gave
up like 10 million dollars just to fight
in Guadalajara yeah it was just to do
his hometown yeah Hometown that was
pretty dope oh my fam My Girl's family
goes nuts for it that's right of course
I didn't I messed up Mr spoiler McGee
here because the you know we're doing
the UFC and I I text him like um heard
about the Canelo fight you know figured
you get a knockout but decision not
worth the 80 bucks huh she's like you
piece of [__] we're watching the UFC and
we recorded you know it oh damn I went
whoops
yeah that sucks my bad my bad I thought
you guys were fans
and even stand away from your phone if
you didn't watch a fight man that's the
that's also Texas don't tell me what
happens because obviously I'm gonna no
yeah
I'm the worst guy that text fights about
I assume you're watching
like when Rogan's not working I'm like
dude how about that knockout but like
don't [__] tell him like how am I
supposed to know you you're hunting
you're talking about me dude it's a big
weekend
I remember like uh I would hear about
like some crazy news stories in MMA and
I'll text you immediately like you
didn't hear about it but then now even
me by the time someone texts me I'm like
I heard about it so many times I don't
bother you unless it's like I found out
like seconds ago and usually I'll know
unless it's a big deal and you know and
like if I'm on stage you know yeah other
than that I'm sure you have a million
people texting you
uh so this is Brandon Moreno calling out
to Henry sudo after his win and he said
that he wouldn't he didn't even care
about the belts they're homies by the
way they're both you know Mexican
interesting uh he said he would go up to
135 to fight uh suhuto like didn't care
about the belts just wants to fight him
in Mexico I mean I'd love that it's a
great fight but I also saw him sudo
because
you know I guess for suhudo people like
go what's he do now you're not so who
knows all about belts and the the Triple
C stuff like that and his plan was to
you know go to 145 and fight volkanovsky
but obviously losing the Sterling takes
that away and he's about belts so part
of me is like yeah well the belt thing's
kind of gone now losing the aljo so the
the
the sugar Shawn fights out the window uh
the Rob fight you know for a title if
you a title holder would have made sense
and then volkanovsky's definitely not
going to fight him now because you know
it doesn't make ton of sense but then
part of me is like a guy like Kenneth
hudo is not gonna retire because he's
waited three years three years to get
himself in this shape three years to get
to this mental place where he wants to
compete I highly doubt winter Lucy's
gonna retire
and I did see Henry sudo get on Twitter
and call it murab
did she beat him Rob yeah man you're
right back where you want to be that
makes the most sense the Murad fight
makes the most sense now it sucks for
our boy Corey sandhagen
because Corey wants to Rob fight to get
that shot but for Henry sahuda Murad
makes a lot of sense yeah but I would
definitely I'm guessing fans would also
think that they would want to see Corey
versus Rob first before especially after
the loss but with UFC it's like you know
I think you're trying to get all the
inner suit before he retires to the
murab fight and for and for aljo
fighting sugar next guaranteed marab's
there he's the rightful you know title
Contender makes sense
makes the most sense unfortunately
um
all right so this was from the UC
embedded I don't because you know Chrome
greasy from I mean
so this was kind of a little a little
bit weird this is uh you know
I'm sure you've done this before you
have to sign posters it takes forever
yes
even your opponent will be there across
from you signing so they were doing this
and then I guess Crone was being cool
with Henry silver for a little bit so
Henry because I don't know if I could
play his clip but Henry's like hey
what's up are you doing blah blah and
then it was cool and then he's like hey
so how's Nate is Nate coming and then uh
krone's like no Nate has his uh kids
birthday party today and then Henry's
like [__] Nate Nate whatever and then
he was like looking at his pictures I
look so good looking Henry said was
saying that about his own picture and
then krone's just like let me know when
he's done and I'll come back
like he was like not in a good Moody
balls he's cutting weight too so some
weight that's what Henry says yeah
Crohn's cut and weight to give Crone a
little bit of uh leeway here he's
cutting weight and then also Chrome
again not only he's fighting style old
school but also's mentality so he
doesn't like the Showmanship the WWE
thing he's not going to play that [__]
he's just not and he knows Henry does
that stuff so he's like I don't want to
be part of this dude let me know when
he's done that's all it is
I don't think it has any reflection on
him as a person I think Henry suit is
the Entertainer he doesn't be part of it
yeah she's not in Chrome Henry said the
same pretty much was like yeah he's
cutting weight he's probably like not in
a good mood
yeah I just don't think he wants to be
he's like dude I'm just trying to sign
these [__] posters and kept the rest
of the weight let me know when it's done
the only part of this
that's all it is yeah all right these
are two pretty heavy ones I'm sure
you've seen this or heard about the
story Jorge Mazda's dad was at Jorge
mozillo's place and apparently shot some
guy twice two times one time in one arm
one time the other arm go so you didn't
kill it's over an argument yeah and I
guess I'm guessing they know each other
and they're in the house yeah it was
late at night
so is that Jesus Christ the dad's mug
shot is tough dude he looks like a
straight up yes like OG you know he
looks how you think Jorge monster doll's
dad looks exactly when you let your son
fight in backyard brawls at 14 this is
exactly what your dad's gonna look like
so attempted murder man how crazy go
away for a hot second dude
yeah especially in Florida
yeah no idea what's going to happen so
far but I mean
yeah I mean I'll tell you what's gonna
happen he's going to prison
yeah I wonder what kind of story they
can uh
with the balance with self-defense who
knows well I'm sure we'll get the rest
of the details but this initial report
is not good if you're a father fan
pretty crazy that's a bummer another
bummer Tony Ferguson
I guess it's around like 2 A.M in
Hollywood he uh he was cornering
somebody though oh was he yeah he's
joined back after a local event I didn't
know that pretty so but there he was by
a club in maybe so after the Corning
they went to a club or something yeah
maybe it's the after fight party yeah
and then um so he crashed into at first
they thought it was two cars but then
they're saying it's four different cars
and this truck flipped over to the side
and he's fine everyone's fine but he's
arrested for DUI and he wouldn't take a
sobriety test
yeah that's what you got to do yeah and
hire Lauren don't say [__] yep yikes but
that sucks and there was video of him
being arrested
um
yeah I hate seeing that [__] man yeah
man
um driving drunk is not cool kids no
sober up got hit four cars just like
crazy eyes out if you didn't Big Daddy
if you're that tossed then yeah
but also Uber
um yeah that's why there's Uber yeah so
Francis ingano remember
it it came out that shot you I don't
think we talked about on the show since
but it came with a shot just said that
he offered him 20 million dollars and
paid three percent exactly yeah but then
there was rumors about shots are saying
that Ghana wanted a seat on the board of
directors or whatever
since then
um I guess Ariel helwani reported that
uh and Ghana called him and said that no
I didn't want to necessarily get a seat
on the directions I wanted to make sure
my opponent got paid the same certain
amount no a certain amount no less than
a certain amount or whatever I forgot
what it was that's silly yeah and then
he just said some promoters man and he
put a two-face meme
I mean a promoters are going to promote
right like they all that's big for a
grain of salt you know
um
you know I I don't know you know if
trachtree did offer him that money he
turned it down I assume you know like we
said before he has some big fish on the
line to turn that down
because let's say that chatri's
exaggerating offered him half of that 10
million guaranteed you've seen an offer
10 million guaranteed 10 mil per fight
is not and a pay-per-view percentage not
so so even if it's half of that you
would assume Francis being a smart guy
has some other big fish on the line now
Cheryl came out and said he signed with
bfl I assume that pfl money is going to
be insane
that is the rumor that's the the most
like supposed to be announced yeah yeah
um yeah I mean what's up but also
promoters gonna promote like remember
when even
um
Scott Coker is a great guy you know
great guy has a good track record come
out and gross we're in negotiation with
Francis there were never negotiations
with Francis
because Bellator knew that pfl is going
to buy them this has been going on for
months I hate to tell you guys most
people in the fight World knew this was
happening so we knew that transaction
was in the process of happening
so if your belt or you're not going to
try and sign
Francis because you know you're going to
be fooled into the pfl banner so pfl is
doing the negotiation but this is what
promoters do they're making bad people
now what they say should you tell you
his word they're businessmen so they're
protecting their business that's all it
is
yeah I mean we've learned a lot about
promoters
since I've since I've worked here I've
been so much more yep
um all right so what do you think about
Karma Usman actually calling out Hamza
shimaya of he said uh
well he says in a good place right now
he's like finally loving getting back
into the training and all that stuff
tomorrow
and then he wanted to fight uh smile
dude we talked about this with uh
we talked about this with dom on the
Cowboys fight companion you just talk
about the balls on camera Usman a
fighters fighter out of all the guys you
want to fight hamzat what yeah insane
hate to fight for Camaro but [__] how
can you not respect Camaro nuts
absolutely nuts now as a homslot fan I
don't see him at 170. it's too much of
weight cut depletes always you know
nutrients I don't want that for him 85
is where it should be at I think since
then he has said like he would go up to
185 to fight Smith come out with oh so
now let me get this check out the
[__]
Nigerian nut sack and Commercial now not
only are you gonna offer a fight with
hamzat but you're gonna meet him at 185.
where the dude's natural weight class is
and you've done 585 you're giving me not
only 170 would be a tough task if even
if homside can make that weight that's
not going to favor Camaro even at 170.
at 185 he probably goes from a four to
one Underdog to eight to one dog you're
talking about foreign world champion the
balls on Camaro how can you not respect
it I hope it's for somebody else at 85 I
don't want Camaro's last fight to be
harms that for a variety of reasons
nothing for homs.2 at 85 Apollo costume
makes more sense there's a lot better
fights at 85 to make for them
uh this is how Al Hamza replied by the
way
someone needs to be poisoned for
retirement
yeah I I don't I hope they don't do that
tomorrow especially 85 what are we doing
yeah but shout out to Camaro dude one of
the goats for a reason
um this is another thing that happened I
think this is a post fight press
conference when Dana White was talking
about the the slap League whenever I see
Dan talk about power slap lately look so
the headline is it's number one off
Sports above NFL NBA NHL F1 WWE combined
first of all that's not true second of
all you know when you move on you break
up with a girl and then she's posted on
Instagram how great her life is it's
like okay okay if you're so happy why
you keep telling us
yeah people that are actually happy and
crushing it don't get well on on Tick
Tock we're doing better in all these
leagues okay
hey dude you made a mistake it's all
good
it's all good yeah and I guess one of
the reporters was from in the name Mania
he was just like I I don't want to be
like disrespectful does that sound like
a isn't it I forgot how he boarded it
but it was funny and then Dana was I
don't give a [__] if you laugh or do you
know don't you think people are laughing
at you not with you something like that
yeah he goes if I'm doing this I'm
making this much you know whatever I'm
selling it for I guess he sold it for as
much as or more than uh after the UFC
after tough something along those lines
he sold it to something and it's do you
give a [__] if they're laughing with me
or at me I don't care because I'm making
the money I'm with Dana yeah if you're
getting yours and we don't know the the
numbers behind it
you know get get yours man yeah so the
deal that I just kept there it is right
slap is bigger than the UC deal we kept
with Spike TV after the first season's
Ultimate Fighter I don't give a [__]
what the media thinks about it they
don't matter it's unbelievable not only
is it unbelievable money-wise it's
unbelievable as far as social media goes
because you can doubt all you want most
of you guys don't understand social
media how it works I'll give you the
numbers on slap that were done by a
third party that does this we didn't
pull the numbers these no these guys are
the Nelson numbers for social media we
destroy everything in sports with
powerslap
yeah so to so does bomb fights so does
Isis beheadings okay
well making money
oh what do you think about this so Rich
Franklin recently said that
Anderson Sylvan Anderson Silva will
always be goat
well he's going to say that because he
fought against and lost true and that
was old school that's old school but
also I understand tested positive yeah
so I'm with you on the I'll never no it
is he passed Anderson and is he beat
Anderson Now Grant is an older Anderson
but he he did beat him and Izzy fought
higher level of competition it's just
these are the facts it's you know I love
I love Anderson he's one of the goats
but uh
as far as body of work Izzy's better
again it's not knock on Anderson it's
just the game the game evolves gets
better is he's fighting better
competition
let me ask you this you think Anderson
Silva would beat
Alex Pierre
no absolutely not
you think Anderson Silver would have
beat Robert Whittaker
twice
nope nope and it's not not gonna answer
it's the it's just love a competition
these days
all right let's just do a couple more
here's a quick one this is about Conor
McGregor's
um I guess auditar their Paradigm team
the management team I guess Pacquiao and
him had issues before
uh and then Pacquiao did a lawsuit well
Pacquiao lost that lawsuit
yeah I saw Connor goes in uh artem
snacks remember yeah take his house
since he doesn't really have money Jesus
dude
I don't know but I mean I hate to see it
artem doing that it's just
Shady all right so I don't know people
are I don't know I wish that was your
boy took care exactly the only reason we
know of you skills Conor people are rats
exactly people suck trust me
so this is in Vegas it's a quick one as
well Nick Diaz and I guess uh I don't
know what happened if Nick was driving
or his friend was driving but apparently
they bumped another car the car was some
sort of music artist and the guy was
trying to like standing up to Nick and
Nick is actually trying to de-escalate
the situation so I'll play it real quick
chill
does he know who Nick is
um
what are you talking about look I said
you're gonna be all right you're gonna
be okay or what you said do I want
something or what I said what is it that
you want oh yeah
[Music]
this is a older Nick who's like uh I
don't need the legal battles here but
this is Young Nick bud you about to find
out the hard way
if there's Nate let me see this guy
okay that's all I saw I saw I guess he
plays I bet his comments are gonna be
fun
foreign
[Music]
now look now it says comments on these
posts have been limited yes and I did
look through it you [__] up there's no
comments trust me I know that that Nick
Nate Diaz fan base will come after you
you have to turn all Scouts off he only
has three posts I saw his videos too I
had to go a way down to see comments but
yeah
they're just like dude do you realize
who the hell you're you could have just
gotten killed or yeah destroyed yeah yes
you escaped an anaconda there my man
yeah yeah
um you know what that's pretty let me
see her
oh this one's kind of a
I wouldn't watch this this guy bit
someone's ear to get a choke and he got
disqualified basically yeah I heard his
uh
he responded was like you think I need
to bite somebody's air together yeah but
when you look at the video yeah dude
that's exactly what you did yeah and he
looks his face I don't know why he looks
like someone that would bite yeah
but you tell kids that are biters too
man I see my son's friends like he's a
biter just have that kids I understand
though I guess
Let's uh do you want have you even heard
about this one yet I don't know if it's
too controversial
uh transgender MMA fighter accepts Jake
Shields fight challenge going to f you
up so Jay Shields says something like I
will take on 10 transgender fighters in
a row yeah something like that and I
guess one of them accepted one was like
I'm in all right where's the other nine
though
and there's no way this guy would this
person would win
no that yeah there's a lot going on
there to dive into
all right
oh here's just a quick one then last one
so Jake Paul Nate Diaz the press
conference is going to be tomorrow May
9th
uh in Dallas where are they doing it I
didn't look at the actual place yeah
that's where the fight's at hell yeah
somewhere in Texas oh yeah yeah Dallas
Texas American Airlines Center dope dope
dope can't wait for that fight
all right let's get out of here dude
what we got for the rest of the weekend
we got a good we got a great Fight Night
rosenstruck Almeida is a fun one the
best find the card
uh man it's a great Fight Night yet uh
and this is ABC you got Anthony Smith
Johnny Walker uh great fight pardon me
as much as I love Anthony Smith I'm
Dynasty Johnny Walker Knox Pierre go at
it so we'll see what happens there but
very tough fight for Johnny Walker
Anthony Smith is a monster all the way
around Daniel Rodriguez Ian Gary is
probably the best find the card great
Alex Morano Tim means they stacked the
stand ABC they stacked it with all
potential fight of the knights they
didn't stack it with superstars though
which is so it's interesting Matt Brown
Court McCree that's a throwback from way
back in the day Carl Williams Chase
Sherman's fund Cody stamen
Carl's ulberg that's a good card really
good card
Brian battle take my money Jessica Rose
Clark little thick doing this damn thing
I'm excited man there's a little
Bellator as well bellatoriately on
Edward's brother fighting Gengar and
Musashi Brent Primus is fighting Douglas
Lima
good fights for the weekend I'm in town
and then there's a UFL as well yeah UFL
on Rumble that's May 13th you got
Rampage Jackson Sun fighting
what's his first name Raja Raja is
fighting yeah and it's actually in
Rampage Hometown it's in Memphis the
three special night for Rampage dude
your main event yeah Trey Manley Angel
Alvarez fighting
lightweight and then they start their uh
their grand prix as well
so you're asking me a fun card that's on
Rumble
cool is that it dude that should be it
all right kids thanks for tuning in
uh your boy locally for most of me I'm
taking off but I'll be doing sets all
around town I have a set Friday night uh
at the Laugh Factory and then Pasadena
shop and Friends Ice House May 19th me
and some monster Comics will be in
Pasadena at the ice house one show only
I think it's at 8pm on May 19th and then
June first week of June Friday Saturday
Sunday La Jolla Comedy Store uh that is
Friday two shows Friday two shows
Saturday one show Sunday in La Jolla
California The Comedy Store and then
starting June 15th I'm jumping over the
pond starts in Belfast June 15th Glasgow
June 17th Manchester June 18th London
June 22nd Cardiff June 23rd I'm ending
the Europe trip in Dublin June 25th in
Ireland that's a theater run one show in
every city get you some right now
thickboy.com I think uh tiger think
merch just went on sale as well when I
say on Friday actually but we're getting
to it today so the new tiger thick merch
you got the maroon hoodies maroon teas
um uh black teas black hoodies all tiger
thick tiger thick whiskey glasses tiger
thick uh steel uh ice cubes some dope
stuff so if you support tiger thick come
get you some thick boy.com and we're
back 59.99 across the board so get you a
bottle while you're at it all right all
right kids that's it ice house I will
see you May 19th and then La Jolla uh
first week of June I'm off uh to Europe
starting June 15th in Belfast teaches at
thick boy.com merch whiskey thick
boy.com love you guys hope you enjoyed
the fights cop ass fight Japan's
available right now uh go tune in it's
with the great Dominic Cruz it's a fun
one so go enjoy thanks for watching like
subscribe love you guys until next week
see ya